she said i always have to try to have
three different
conflicts happening to the character at
the same time and they're all not
of the same magnitude so for example
can you explain how you outline a
screenplay yeah so outlines um
i'd say so first you have the idea right
or you have the
the concept so to speak um
and some people have high concepts you
know like
which are easier to explain in a few
words
um
i usually have low concepts in the sense
that they're character driven and
that's in a way it's more challenging
because you gotta find out what makes
them distinctive from
other ideas you know the maybe the juice
the beauty of it is not in the concept
but in the world and the character
so um
i i do a beat sheet first um and i use
an exercise
that uh hal ackerman talks about who i
had class with at ucla called snow
plowing
and snow plowing is basically um
you set out a certain amount of time it
could be 20 minutes could be 40 or an
hour usually you don't do more than an
hour at a time
and um you write down
possible scenes
um without judging them and not not
stopping right so
it doesn't matter if they contradict one
another you just keep going
so um because they're just possibilities
they're not the whole final thing
um
and ideally you know you write i don't
use a computer then i just write it down
manually and
let's say you do 20 minutes and you just
go nonstop don't because if you stop
you're gonna judge it and the point is
not to judge yourself the point is to
discover
so you do this exercise a few times over
and over again and then you go back to
it and then you pick and discard like
okay this is good
this one not you know doesn't work or
i'm gonna just pick this option
and i'd say after a few times you're
doing that you start having a sense of
what the structure is
of course you can also guide yourself
with with uh books right now save the
cat has an option of what a structure is
i mean i feel like intuitively you know
that your structure needs
um
ups and downs and and beats of all kinds
and you kind of have a midpoint
um
so by doing by snow plowing and then by
going back to the idea of structure you
come up with the beats and once you have
the beats
which are the bones
the outline
is like giving that connective tissue
right so
um once i'm confident about my beachy
then
i just start filling out
those bones with yeah with flesh which
is
not too much detail but enough detail to
connect the scenes and make sure that
there's a cause and effect relationship
between them
and you just expand
so i would say there's i mean
i don't skip any of the steps
you know from idea i go to beat sheet
from bc i go to outline
i don't need my outlines to be too
detailed i just need them to have the
necessary information especially if i
want to have like setups and payoffs
i want to make sure those are in the
outline
and then you just start writing
when you're writing these scenes that
you don't want to judge and they might
be random scenes
are they ones you've already had in your
mind or are you almost manufacturing
them
so that the most
you know ridiculous idea like this would
never really happen and then once you go
back and look at it you think well
actually we could lead to that
no the point is to to surprise yourself
actually
um
so i you know
it's a very
different the creative mind that you
apply is very different you know you
have like your
right side of the brain and your left
side of the brain right and i feel like
most of the time in the real world we're
we're being very rational
so
if you start writing from that
perspective you're going to come up with
probably conventional ideas and there's
nothing wrong with cliches by the way
i think they're a great starting point
when you don't know what to do just
write down the cliche
so you can get it out of the way
that's better than nothing
uh and sometimes i feel we get blocked
because you know you try to write the
most original thing ever
and you don't do that right away it's
really hard so maybe it's easier to
write a cliche and then
you know maybe change a few things and
and maybe let it evolve and turn
or
you know for example i i always want to
set a scene in the most original
location right
so
instead of setting it at
the character's house which would be the
obvious thing because they're going to
discuss something intimate what if
they're in church
right and that of course makes the
conversation more awkward and maybe
funny and they can't really talk
great but is that does it serve the
story you know you don't want to be
eccentric just for the sake of being
eccentric
um
but maybe maybe you plan the scene in
the character's house
and then once you have it okay what if i
change the location
you know and maybe and maybe it works
but you don't you don't go all the way
at once you know you want to take it
gradually and
once you have it okay if i change
location would she say this in public
if she said this in public would maybe
it's funny maybe it's ridiculous i don't
know
um
sorry i got lost in my own logic there
oh yeah so originality i feel like it's
desirable to be original and you don't
want to be lazy
but sometimes some scenes can only take
place
in one location right
i mean if the character is in prison
they're not infinite options right
if someone's visiting they can only meet
in the visiting space right there's no
other option
um but if you have time and then you
know and and
and you want to make it better maybe
explore with certain scenes unexpected
locations
can you give me examples of these
cliches
what's a cliche uh well i mean with
characters it's easy because
stereotypes and archetypes right um and
we see this all all the time so um
you know the cop the preacher the
prostitute right uh
the
bossy
wife um
we don't want to play those characters
exactly the way
as they sound because we've seen that
and it's boring and
um if if the audience is smart
let's not underestimate the audience
the audience has seen a lot of movies
read a lot of books whatever they know
so um if you're going to play with
stereotypes or archetypes
you better find a way to make them
slightly different
or maybe start you know tony soprano
right tony soprano is a gangster that
goes to therapy if he was just a
gangster they'll be like okay i've seen
good fellas you know
why am i even watching this but tony
soprano has an issue
again i'm going on you know very classic
example but
he has an emotional issue he's a
gangster you know and now it doesn't
surprise us but back in the day with the
sopranos what 95 96 i don't know when it
came out
it was it was an amazing concept
um
you know and sometimes
um you know it happened to me i have to
wear gangsters so what do i do with
gangsters
what haven't i seen with gangsters
i don't know gangsters singing gangsters
crying what can i do with him
gangster that doesn't want to be a
gangster but it has to it's forced by
his family yeah or her family yeah that
could lead somewhere um
as long as you can find
to me the most difficult thing is
finding the yeah the emotional
connection
and by emotional i don't mean i have to
laugh or cry all the time it's just that
it resonates
um
that it makes them three-dimensional
human
and that that your intuition says this
is something that a lot of humans could
relate to right that i
um
it's just that's you know it's
since writers are usually very smart as
as
as a teacher as an instructor used to
tell me in grad school the smartest
people in the room
um
we have a lot of ideas
and i don't mean that in a good way
ideas are are a problem because
um
you might um get away with them and
there's nothing in you there it's just
you know we have we have stored all
these ideas
and i'm like well what if you know uh
what if the cops don't suddenly decides
to rob the bank
sure it sounds fun but what's what's in
there that you care about
you know why do you relate to that
because he's having a crisis you know
about his identity and his profession
well now we're on to something then it's
not about robbing the bank it's about
what if a cop no longer believes in the
law because he thinks the system is
crooked i don't know i'm making this up
okay that's actually interesting
tell me more so i feel like um
yeah it's about finding your
personal connection
okay so we we know some some cliche
character
archetypes what about scenes
what are some things you see students do
or maybe you did in the beginning that
they were too cliche whether it's
showing up at the best friend's wedding
and
you know
you know does anyone here object and
then you know just what the typical
romantic comedy
i would say um
scenes about couples arguing
uh
tend to lead to a lot of cliches
especially if you just play them out
very dramatically and i'm not saying
couples don't have very dramatic
arguments because they do
but what if you introduce certain
elements in there that makes suddenly
the scene
different and i'm going to quote on this
phoebe waller bridge
she said something that i loved and i
blew my she's such an amazing everything
but
she said i always have to try to have
three different
conflicts happening to the character at
the same time and they're all not
of the same magnitude so for example
she needs to get an abortion it's very
hot in the room
and she doesn't like how her hair looks
so she's trying to figure out or tell
her significant other that she needs to
get an abortion while checking herself
in the mirror while also noticing that
she has sweaty armpits
so she writes comedy mostly so that i
can see how that can be
a dramedy right it's very dramatic but
it's also very funny because she's
distracted
so if the scene were just her saying we
need to talk i'm pregnant and i need to
get rid of the baby okay
sure that can be a compelling scene but
it's also
i don't know if you play that way it's a
bit conventional
but if she's concerned about her hair
then
that sounds very
human and she's seeing that she's
sweating yes and she's wondering did the
baristas see me this sweaty and
disgusting exactly there's so many
options and she feels like oh my god i'm
pregnant i don't want to be pregnant i'm
gross you know like ugh i've never felt
so ugly i wish my hair was like straight
you know
so sure i i think that's that's great
advice
and it's your brothers
well
i
just took it to a whole different way
no no i'm not judging you i'm just
saying
okay um
just that that would take the cliche
that would also spin it you know you
know you know what's interesting though
that opens up because i have this
conversation this morning about tone and
i feel like um tone is such an important
uh element in a story and um
it's something i do think about right
away
even though i can't i don't think i can
avoid it tone um it's really hard to
define what it is but you recognize it
right and most of the
creators or filmmakers we love have a
very specific tone like the coen
brothers have a very specific
kind of ironic sarcastic
almost sometimes almost depressing tone
uh you know it's about plot it's about
character you don't really know where
it's at but it's you can sense it
um
and i was i was breaking down a story
today actually and um
i followed the story through where it
led me and at some point it led to a
very dark
area
that i got scared off
and by the way i would say getting
scared of something is a good sign
because you know it says it means
there's something
very personal to explore
but at the same time i felt it was so
dark that it
destroyed my tone
you know and i got worried i would lose
my audience
that's one of those moments where you
feel like
if i cringe
in not in an interesting way you know
maybe it's worth considering
that direction
and i think it's a valid point
sure so you know that you kind of took
it too far and
it wouldn't work for the story
um
well i don't mind telling you what what
it is because i'm not going to use it i
mean
i had
i had a character with a situation and
she's trying to figure out how she feels
and why she feels so uncomfortable about
what's happening to her right and she
doesn't know
which is i mean it's odd it's not a
story where you know she's trying to get
money and no the goal of the character
is to figure out why she feels the way
she feels right a situation triggered a
feeling and she doesn't understand it
and it's a very odd thing i mean i don't
know why i do this to myself because
it's not something tangible first of all
you've got to be really careful do i
want to talk about this subject am i
qualified to talk about it does it
actually resonate with me or does it
just sound
you know like it would have an impact
and my gut feeling was like don't go
there
don't go there because once you
introduce certain topics the story is
done unless you want to discuss the
consequences of that and i don't want to
be the person doing that you know and
because i haven't been through it and i
i hope it doesn't happen to me and i
gotta be respectful
but if my tone is kind of playful you
gotta be really careful where you go
some things are just not gonna be funny
that's a good point you know no matter
how you approach it sure it's not funny
sure
like the vibe is dead
yeah yeah because then you can't from
that point on
it can't be around comedy it can't be
another element in your story yeah you
either make your story about that
because you actually will have something
to say or refrain from it
you know
but that you know
that's
i mean i i want to be really careful not
everything is material for storytelling
unless
you know like michaela cole who did i
may destroy you and you know the show is
about that but she went through it
you know yeah the only thing i could
think of is that if you showed the
character's life up until that point
that was light and fun
and then if
something horrible happens and then
how their life changes drastically after
that
but yeah you can't continue but the
story then is about that and
by the way i'm not against horrible
things happening to your character i
mean
i'm just saying they're they're
boundaries to me
um
and they're things that i haven't
experienced that i i'd rather not talk
about